سنحقق النصر. وان اضطر الامر ان
نخترق حدود بولندا. اسمعتم? هكذا
فجرتها موسكو. فهل حان وقت توسع
الحرب الروسية خارج اوكرانيا?
والزلنسكي يرد سنهزم الجميع.
والامم المتحدة تدين الروس
باغلبية تامة. وبوتين لم نصب
بالجنون بعد. عقوبات جديدة ضد
روسيا وطباخ بوتين يقترب من هاني
باخموت. واردوغان يتدخل ليعلن
الوساطة باي طريقة ممكنة.
والجنود الامريكان يصلون تايوان.
هل اشتعل فتيل الحرب? والصين
تعترف لهذا السبب قدمنا مبادرة
لانهاء الحرب في اوكرانيا.
والمجنون يضع الملح في الجراح
الامريكية معلنا تحديه بهذا
الاجراء العسكري. فهل من مبارز?
زلزال يصل حدود الصين والعالم
ينبئ بكارثة جديدة. مفارم اللحم
الروسي تقترب. بعد دخول العام
الجديد على الحرب اشتدت الاحداث
ضراوة حول اوكرانيا وظلت هي
الشغل الشاغل للدول العالمي. هنا
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
يشير الى ان الخطر النووي يتصاعد
لكنه اكد ان روسيا لم تصب
بالجنون ولن تكون اول من يبدأ
باستخدام النووية تحت اي ظرف.
مضيفا ان الحرب في اوكرانيا قد
تكون عملية طويلة. اذا فلتملأ
مخازنكم بالغذاء يا اصدقاء،
فالحرب لا زالت طويلة جدا. الرد
ياتي من الجمعية العامة للامم
المتحدة والتي تبنت باغلبية
الاصوات والتي يقدر عددها بمائة
وواحد واربعين صوتا قرارا يجدد
مطالبة روسيا بسحب كل قواتها
وبشكل كامل ومن دون اي شرط من
اراضي اوكرانيا. كما يدعو القرار
الى وقف الاعمال العدائية مهلا
مهلا. فان كل تلك الاصوات من
القضية الفلسطينية ليأتي اول رد
روسي من مندوب موسكو الاممي.
والذي قال ان مجلس الامن تحول
الى اداة خاصة لاوكرانيا في ظل
الرئاسة الحالية. لتعلن واشنطن
انها ستقدم ملياري دولار في حزمة
اضافية من المساعدات الامنية
لاوكرانيا. لكن الامين العام
للناتو يرى الامور بطريقة مغايرة
ويقول ان انتصار اوكرانيا على
ارض المعركة هو الطريق الذي
سيوصل الى المفاوضات والحلول
السلمية. ليأتي الدور على الرئيس
الاوكراني زلنيسكي الذي قال ان
الرابع والعشرين من فبراير هو
اصعب يوم في تاريخ اوكرانيا
الحديث. مضيفا ان اوكرانيا لن
ترفع الراية البيضاء وقد نجحت
ولم تهزم بل ستهزم الجميع وفق
قوله هنا قال الامين العام للامم
المتحدة ان حياة الاوكرانيين
اصبحت جحيما حقيقيا. سنرد نحن
هذه المرة. فلماذا لم تروا
الجحيم ذاته في حرب العراق
وافغانستان واليمن وسوريا. لنكمل
ليعود زينيسكي ويقول ان انتصار
اوكرانيا امر حتمي اذا الغربيون
بوعودهم. مجموعة السبع استجابت
للرئيس الاوكراني مؤكدة نيتها
تعزيز الدعم الاقتصادي لاوكرانيا
في عام الفين وثلاثة وعشرين الى
تسعة وثلاثين مليار دولار بناء
على احتياجات حكومة اوكرانيا
بحسب سبوتنيك. الحرب تخرج شيئا
فشيئا خارج حدود اوكرانيا. ونائب
رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي ميدفيديف
يؤكد عزم موسكو على النصر في حتى
وان كان ذلك يعني حدود بولندا
ولن تتوقف الحرب في بولندا حيث
تهدد موسكو بالرد اذا تعرضت في
مولدافيا لهجوم بحسب سكاي نيوز.
لكن مولدافيا تنفي اي تهديد
مباشر من كييف لهذه المنطقة
الانفصالية. وبالعودة الى
الاراضي الاوكرانية حيث الحرب
الحقيقية. هنا طباخ بوتين وقائد
فاجنر يتقدم في الصفوف الامامية
على جبهة باخموت ويبعث برسالة
تهنئة للروس بمناسبة يوم المدافع
عن الوطن. ليعلن ان مقاتليه
سيطروا بشكل كامل على قرية
بريخيفكا الاوكرانية احدى ضواحي
مدينة باخموت الشمالية الغربية.
اما الاوكران ومع كل هذا الدعم
الغربي فاعلن وزير دفاعهم
التحضير لهجوم مضاد على القوات
الروسية يشمل البر والبحر والجو
الافتراضي وفق وكالة فرانس بريس
فهل تفعلها كييف حقا ام انها
مجرد احلام لتأتي الاجابة من
وزير الدفاع الامريكي لود اوستن
حيث قال انه على الارجح سينتهي
الامر باحد انواع المفاوضات.
ويقصد هنا مفاوضات منتصر لمهزوم
او مفاوضات مهزوم لمنتصر وذلك
وفق شبكة سي ان ان. لينضم الرئيس
التركي اردوجان الى هذا الرأي
بقوله ان تركيا مستعدة لحل
الازمة بين روسيا واوكرانيا باي
طريقة ممكنة بحسب وكالة
الاناضول. ومن هناك عاد الغرب
نحو العقوبات. حيث فرضت وزارة
الخزانة الامريكية عقوبات جديدة
على البنوك الروسية واستهدفت
قطاع التعدين والمعادن الروسي مع
ملاحقة اكثر من ثلاثين شخصية
وشركة من سويسرا والمانيا ودول
اخرى لمساعدتها موسكو في تمويل
حربها على اوكرانيا التي دخلت
عامها الثاني. بينما قالت وزارة
الخارجية البريطانية ان العقوبات
والاجراءات التجارية المنسقة
دوليا ستستهدف قطع غيار الطائرات
واجهزة اللاسلكي والمكونات
الالكترونية. الصين تتوسط الحرب.
الحرب ولا شيء غيرها سيحسم
الموقف بين الصينيين
والامريكيين. فكل الطرق الى تلك
الحرب الطاحنة لتعود امريكا الى
زيادة جنودها في تايوان من بوابة
التدريب حيث يعزز الجيش الامريكي
وجوده هناك وتحديه للصين.
فالقوات الامريكية في تايوان
تسعى لتدريب الجيش تحسبا لاي
هجوم صيني. حرب اخرى تثير التوتر
بين بكين وواشنطن. انها الحرب
الاوكرانية. هنا وزير الخارجية
الامريكي بلينكن يقول وصلتنا
معلومات تفيد بان الصين تفكر
بتزويد روسيا بالاسلحة. ليطلق
بلينكين تهديده قائلا انه لا
يعتقد ان الصين تريد ان تواجه
مزيدا من العزلة الدولية فيما
تدرس ادارة الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن نشر معلومات استخباراتية
تعتقد انها تدل على ان الصين
تنظر في امكانية تزويد روسيا
باسلحة لدعم حربها في اوكرانيا.
بحسب صحيفة جورنال لتضيف الصحيفة
ان الصين قلقة من تداعيات فشل
روسيا في الحرب. ليخرج كبير
الدبلوماسيين الصينيين وانجي
وينفي الاتهامات الامريكية بشأن
تزويد الصين لروسيا بالاسلحة
ووصفها بالافتراءات. مؤكدا ان
بكين تسعى للسلام بطريقتها
الخاصة. فهل قدمت واشنطن كل هذه
الاتهامات فقط لان الصين ارادت
التوسط للسلام في اوكرانيا? كيم
يضع الملح في جراح واشنطن. عندما
غاب كيم جونغ عن الساحة قليلا
استدعى جيرانه واشنطن للقيام
بالمناورات عاد المجنون ليذكرهم
بوجوده لتضرب كوريا الشمالية
بتحذيرات الولايات المتحدة عرض
الحائط. وتطلق اربعة صواريخ
استراتيجية جديدة من طراز كروز
باتجاه البحر لتقول وكالة
الانباء اليابانية ان تجربة
الجديدة اظهرت مرة اخرى قوة
بيونج يانج القتالية النووية تلك
الصواريخ في بحر اليابان الذي
اصبح مسرحا لعمليات تجارب صواريخ
المجنون. لتعلنها الخارجية
الكورية الشمالية. ان الولايات
المتحدة يجب ان تعي انه اذا
واصلت ممارساتها العدوانية
والاستفزازية ضد كوريا الشمالية
فيمكن اعتبار ذلك بمثابة اعلان
حرب ضد بلاد وفق وكالة الانباء
المركزية الكورية الشمالية.
الاحداث والتطورات. الغاء اكثر
من ثلاثة الاف وخمسمائة رحلة
جوية بسبب عاصفة ثلجية شلت
الحركة في الولايات المتحدة.
زلزال بقوة سبعة فاصل اثنين درجة
على مقياس ريختر يضرب الحدود ما
بين الصين وطاجيكستان والعالم
الهولندي فرانك هوجر بيتس يحذر
من ان الاسبوع من شهر مارس
القادم سيكون حرجا. الكيان
الاسرائيلي يرفع حالة التأهب
خوفا من الرد الفلسطيني على
مجزرة نابلس. الامم المتحدة
تواجه موسكو بقراراتها وواشنطن
تتحدى بكين فالى اين سيتم